[Musique]
attention gad tu dois que tu dois
choisir entre deux fois ci craignent non
mégarde ou franck dubosc d'accord tu as
le choix si tu dois regarder qu'un c'est
horrible tu vas y je sais tu as tourné
tu as tourné fiston avec franck dubosc
je les adore je les adore les deux c'est
très compliqué de peut pas dire gaïdar
boss contre pas bien sûr que tu choisis
pas il meurt pas vraiment mais non c'est
je sais pas râler cyril je sais pas du
tout aller ouais ça va dit la vérité
mais gadret ciguatera je vous avais tu
sais que tu aime beaucoup franck voilà
nos jeunes c'est pas que j'aime beaucoup
j'adore franck et je trouve que c'est un
de nos meilleurs comédiens français font
menacer c'est bien parce que cette fois
que les mecs joli spectacle et faire des
gros concurrents ce mardi
mais non parce que parce que tu es
obligé de dire aussi ce que tu penses de
laurie bien sûr parce qu'on joue tu
choisis donc naturellement tu aimes bien
reziga à l'an prochain attention
prochain psg ou alors c'est tout faux je
choisir oui c'est horrible ah ouais le
psg web et d'un petit frère je regarde
pas le foot c'était bien quand même l'om
et j'aime j'adore l'om et je que j'adore
tous les matchs de foot je regarde pas
le foot donne un petit frère jean tigana
qui a 10 ans il ouvre de paris donc pour
lui paris sans charme attention moi je
les choix j'aime mais j'aime bien des 2
au 6 e alors capucines à naves ou joyce
jonathan
je rappelle qu apparemment il y en a une
que taper chaud il ya trois ans il y en
a une qui t'a pris un râteau huawei
écouter des histoires qui sont complexes
ces deux histoires sont complexes alors
tout honneur d'homme comme capucine qui
est la une qui est pas là donc choisi
bien sûr mais surtout j'ai d'ailleurs tu
me menace de jonathan
merci
attention la mégère beaucoup capus si je
la trouve super ton père ou sa mère
danseuse a assez duré
je dirais mon père guy j'adore laurence
pareil mais j ai quand même hein et
quand même un personnage particulier
dans le monde de la télé du cinéma
alors regardez prochain bruit alors la
belle vanessa vanessa hudgens ou les
fesses de rihanna rihanna
moi je vais choisir sans hésitation
rihanna alors tu t'étais prix en rien un
râteau par est des prix a rigolé tu as
tenté un truc avec vanessa dans tpm pee
wee dans tpm puis je m'en rappelle
regardez merci attention les profs ou
soda hu a ouais ouais je vais dire je
vais dire soda parce que j'ai évidemment
les profs c'est fait c'est très
important dans ma vie mais ces audaces a
été le monde mais desbuquois donc chaude
à pension iv semi tonnerre au charlotte
qu'ironique étaient mus côte d'azur
sortie tous les noces quoi tous les
noces invasion une émission ce qu'on va
rapper valu des rumeurs avec emi
tonnerre oui donc état tweets et à 10 et
on voit là et a dit à voix là écoute je
te confirme on est si comme moi vous
êtes vous êtes en couple mais que vous
n'êtes pas au courant
là c'est chelou c'est ce que ta vie et
c'est ça c'est ça au créa l'avoir akerys
iris jeu effectivement on sort ensemble
mais je n'ai pas encore rencontré
donc c'est une histoire un peu à
distance pour l'instant alors et charles
tu as connu charlotte échalotes on sait
on
[Rires]
ben alors j'arrête est une super fille
très jamais serré mais on est très
content et elle est très sympa elle est
venue nous voir un jour ici il était
très sympathique
merci bah c'est bon à enlever cette
photo c'est bon c'est bon choisir quoi
que vous soyez ce qui je choisis eris
merci ea vise voilà c'est fait et bien
merci
[Applaudissements]